bonjour à tous là on est sur le stand de
panasonic hausses et baisses et ils
viennent de faire une présentation de ce
que pourrait être la voiture du futur
[Musique]
une voiture complètement autonome où
vous n'auriez plus du tout sans conduire
à votre ce qu'on a tout seul et vous
auriez un intérieur comme en intérieur
salon des sièges face à face des écrans
de partout au plafond sur les côtés sur
les fenêtres
vous pourriez complètement interagir
avec les écrans c'est à dire écrire
dessus envoyer des messages vous auriez
des compartiments pour avoir vos
boissons fraîches
enfin les trajets en voiture serait plus
du tout la même chose c'est un petit peu
un concept c'est un concept car ça
n'existe pas encore aujourd'hui mais on
voit un petit peu l'idée de ce que
pourrait être effectivement la voiture
du futur et de quelle manière on
pourrait le dépasser plus tard c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'hyper
intéressant parce que ça pose déjà
beaucoup de questions sur la mobilité
sur le nombre de personnes qu'on va
naître dans une voiture de telle manière
on va déplacer là ce qu'on voit c'est
que c'est un produit qui est très haut
de gamme
on est vraiment dans cette idée
effectivement de la conduite de
l'automobile haut de gamme
bien évidemment tout le monde demain ne
pourra pas avoir un salon privé un salon
hyper luxueux dans sa voiture avec une
nature 100% au trône
mais l'idée en tout cas ce que ça montre
c'est vraiment une vision du futur est
une idée du futur par panasonic du bon
son les bons écrans de la détente des
trajets plus fatigant imaginez-vous
partir en vacances dans un véhicule
comme ça la voiture se gère
automatiquement
vous n'avez rien à faire vous êtes
reposé vous pouvez faire la sieste boire
un coup
regarde un film envoyer des messages
c'est vraiment une idée géniale
alors on en n'est absolument pas encore
là aujourd'hui on est au tout début des
voitures autonomes pour l'instant la
réglementation n'est pas
particulièrement là pour laisser les
voitures autonomes sur la route mais on
va y arriver très rapidement et dans
quelques années on aura plus du tout
l'habitude de conduire son véhicule
les véhicules se conduiront tout seul ce
qui veut dire plus d'accidents ce qui
veut dire moins contrainte
ce qui veut dire des routes beaucoup
plus fluide ça veut dire énormément de
choses donc on voit très bien que au
niveau du futur au niveau des véhicules
du futur
on a vraiment quelque chose de nouveau
quelque chose qui se précise alors on en
est vraiment encore très très très très
loin
là on va se rapprocher tout doucement
des véhicules autonomes besoin aux
environs de 2020 2025 de tentes à
législation se met en place
distribution se fasse que les véhicules
soient là donc on n'y est pas du tout
encore tout de suite mais ce qu'on voit
réellement c'est qu'il ya un engouement
une vision du futur des choses qui sont
vraiment passionnante dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne chose est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est intéressant
est ce que vous seriez pas un peu
frustré si vous aimez conduire dire moi
je peux plus conduire au final ma
voiture c'est une extension de la maison
mais qu'est ce que je vais faire avec
est ce que ça vous intéresse marquer
votre sans commentaire parce que c'est
vraiment quelque chose de super
intéressant comme d'habitude vous invite
à laisser des jolies pousse à vous
abonner et on reste connectés parce
qu'il va y avoir toujours plus de
contenu high tech que ce soit pour vos
smartphones aux ordinateurs la maison
connectée à vous reconnecter et tous ses
concerts les nouvelles technologies je
vous dis à bientôt sur les âges et vous
embrasse ciao
[Musique]